anyway listen I'm a huge fan of your
show and I'm just curious for you guys
it's I you know Greg Daniels was telling
me that it's I think the number one
comedy on Prime video I'm curious for
for all three of you when did you
realize oh wait people are really
watching this
show well I was getting I forget that
it's dropped in what is it like 40
different languages all at once at the
same time I mean when I get a DM in any
language that I don't speak but
especially like Korean or Portuguese or
I mean you name it that that really like
oh that always surprises me and I I'm
I'm still not used to it um but but I
I'm also really moved by the fact that a
story that can feel in some ways quote
unquote Western because it's technology
and because it's LA and because it's New
York I don't know but that it speaks to
so many different people from so many
many different countries is like oh oh
yeah there's something really
thematically true here um and I think
that's pretty cool yeah I agree I think
um it was you know we we said that one
of the like crazy parts of the timing of
the first season dropping was everybody
was locked in their house during covid
so you know I wouldn't trade our timing
for Co I would reverse it for sure but
you know one of the one of the nice
things for us was people were home so
they watched our show but it still
wasn't like a runaway Smash Hit it just
kind of got a nice jump and people have
steadily found the show on Prime video
from you know over because it's been a
long time in the making like we shot the
we the first season came out in 2020 in
what February or March of 2020 so we're
now three years later um and uh we shot
it back in 2018
um the first first the pilot and then
shot the first season 2019 but it's been
a long time coming for us and and I feel
like the crazy thing for me is whenever
I'm in an airport I get picked off for
upload and like algra said it's kind of
people from everywhere like doesn't
matter where the flight is going people
are picking me off from upload which
which is really cool it it shows you
know the global reach of the show which
is is very fun yeah I mean I don't have
much much else to add honestly except
that yeah it's I feel like we we're a
bit of a sleeper show like it's not a
show that like is I don't know it
doesn't feel like it's this like ah
we're everywhere and even though we are
you know it's but what has been so
beautiful is those that do watch the
show absolutely love it like there are
like upload stands you know and like
they're so excited so so I think I hope
that the show continues to grow and and
and I and yes we are the number one
comedy on Prime video but beyond that
it's like oh yeah I think for the kind
of show when you do watch it you fall in
love with it and so so I'm I'm excited
for us to keep growing that that way so
so more and more people get to
experience um the Journey of it so since
the entire season 3 is out I love this
we can talk spoilers so for all three of
you uh which naan do you think is on the
phone at the end of
the okay Nathan on the phone I think
that Nathan on the phone saying the
other one was destroyed I think that
Nathan is backup Nathan and and Robbie's
been doing a good job of this prefacing
it by saying I have no idea no one has
told me anything not that they would I
also haven't really asked because I like
to be surprised but but this is just a
straightup guess I think that it's back
up on the Phil that's who I think I've
asked and they have not told me anything
um I'm I've been so pushy and nosy and
they're they're not you know they're not
budging so
yeah I I hope it's um you know real
Nathan meet Nathan I hope it's him and
um selfishly for Nora yeah I think it's
up to Nathan I don't think they're going
to know which one it is so whichever one
he wants to be he can just choose to be
that
this is when this is like Nathan
becoming an actor Arc Nathan a lot in
common gosh and is playing everybody for
a
fool he would tell Luke immediately
that's
what yes yeah I actually wonder I I
asked Greg about it I did a long talk
with him and I actually wonder if they
even know because I think sometimes
writers just like to write to a point
and then you know the writer room will
figure it out and what's the best
version of the show if we go this way or
this way yeah this is entirely possible
I want to switch actually um uh for you
guys what was your reaction when you
found out the whole storyline of season
3 and where it was all going um I'm just
curious what was your take on it all I'm
actually a huge fan of the show I mean
if I wasn't on it I wouldn't watch it
because I'd be so pissed off that I
didn't book the role
but but if I was never up for the role
and I and I saw the show come out I
would be a huge fan I'm I'm a huge fan
of our cast I think they're very funny
they make me laugh onset and they make
me laugh when I'm watching the show um
but I'm a huge fan of Greg and Owen and
the rest of the writers I think they do
such a good job of hitting this
satirical comedy and romance and asking
interesting questions and it can be a
show that you can kind of sit back and
watch and laugh or it can be a show that
you can have some pretty like pretty
serious conversations about with friends
and family and um I think that the the
show's subjective I think that you know
I think it's nice that people won't
always have the same opinion about um
how things work out on the show or or
some of the the themes of the show um
but it's never feels like it's shoving
it down your throat it's kind of just
posing questions and letting you you
know um make make your own decisions uh
so I'm you know I'm just a huge fan of
the show so I'm always excited to read
the new episodes when they come out and
then
selfishly um seeing two versions of me
was you know scary and exciting and and
was going to be something I had never
done before and and something that I was
you know excited to tackle um and it
meant that I have two amazing actresses
to have a relationship with on the show
and and and play off of and see two
different sides of it so I was I was
very spoiled this season I'm always
excited by um what kind of ethical
question uh Greg and the writers are
going to choose to sort of examine and
how are they going to do it and some
examples from this season would be like
the um the the Meat Plant where they
just took in you know the the um tumor
the cancerous tumor is good for pork too
and there's just a barn full of tumor um
which is horrendous but also like whoa
you guys what if or or like you know if
everybody is in goggles like trying to
live their best lives and the I saw an
interview between Mark Zuckerberg and um
oh gosh I forget what um what journalist
it was but they had the entire interview
in VR and and so so anytime I read the
script and I go what are they gonna poke
at you know this season we get a little
bit of election fraud we little we get a
little bit of like workers rights um and
uh and labor and I'm I'm like oh they're
just little threads and they're small
questions that get bigger and bigger um
but that's that's what I look forward to
reading is what what philosophical
debate are they going to kind of ignite
with just like a little rock in the
pond yeah I mean just
to add on to to what you're saying aler
made me think about something I I just
learned about is there's they're wanting
to make chicken from uh in a lab from
cells um and and grow grow chicken um
and I'm like wow that's so
interesting and but our show really
really opens up these conversations uh
if you want you know like Robbie was
saying or or you just watch it along and
you're just like wow this is nuts and
kind of
surreal um but I think in in reading
this this
season I think I was just really excited
for Nora and Nathan to really experience
like a relationship in in the real world
and um and and see what that's like you
know and that that was kind of fun have
you guys heard anything about like has
has Prime video or anyone involved said
hey guys can you please uh save the
dates you know March through May of uh
2024 is that what they told you did they
tell you that
no get information out of you guys God
we hope so you know it's funny we will
probably find out about four hours
before you find out that's kind of how
it works we normally get the like Hey
we're doing it also uh here's the press
release for approval great thanks
[Laughter]
okay we love it fingers crossed yeah
there's there's I would be stunned if
you guys aren't doing season 4 just
absolutely stunned top 10 in Amazon and
if you see your show near the top you
you're pretty safe you know what I mean
yeah we're in good company and uh you
know I would never bet against Greg
Daniels yeah yeah I'm pretty confident I
think we're going to get a season 4 I
have no um knowledge or expertise in
this department but absolutely I'm I
think we
are confidence yeah I agree listen I got
a wrap already uh I'm just GNA say I
really enjoy this really enjoy your work
love the show have a fantastic day with
the rest of the speed dating thanks
really appreciate great
dat